Ch住 ngày 28 tháng 3, tại chú sở chính phụ, thu tướng phạm mình chính, bí thưa đảng uì chính phụ
chủ trí của họp ban tượng vụ đảng uì chính phụ.
Chơi kiến về việc bấn hành mù hình chính quyền địa phương 2 cấp,
bàn ra còn li tại sản công và trình bị hội gỹ tổng kết chương trình sóa nhà tạm,
rộn át.
Pụ tướng nhân mạnh, biêu đành ra sau gần 2 tháng trình 2 là cần thiết để kiệt thời thảo gữa hó khăn,
vấn mắc, bảo đam bấn hành thông xuất, đồng bộ.
Kết quả mức đầu khẳng định sự đúng đánh của chủ chương, sự đồng thận cao của hệ thống chính trị, sự uống ộ của nhân dân,
sân nghiệp, cải các khảnh chính đường đẩy máy lộ hồ sơ chực tiến đặt bẩy mấy tư phẩy mẩy phần trăm.
Mình cảnh đó vẫn còn nhiều thách thức nhiều sắp sẽ nhìn sự, tài sản, cơ sự hạt tân, số hoa, sự liệu.
Đến ngày 15 tháng 3, có mùi sống nghìn 1,5 mùi tâm hà mi tư cơ sở nhớ đất dưới dư cần sự lý,
không sảo trong sả chưa đáp ứng đủ chang Thích bị trên chimét tương nghiên cán bộ, công chức bên chức đặt có quy định nghiệp theo chính xanh.
Tụ tưởng yêu cầu các bộ, ngành để phương tức tục ra sóa thảo ở vấn mắc, khoảng thịt thịt chế bảo đam chính quyền 2 cóp bệnh thành đồng bộ, hiệu quả, phục vụ nhân dân tốt hơn.